DK Metcalf has been in the NFL for four
years and just signed a three-year 72
million dollar contract extension with
the Seattle Seahawks I remember texting
my age like who is uh Uncle Sam where he
come from but he's learned a lot in his
career and his relationship with money
has changed from when he was first
drafted as a 21 year old DK sat down
with us to explain his journey from
football player to businessman along
with his financial advisor Joe McLean a
former athlete himself
what is the first thing you see that
some mistakes they could make or that
you want them to stay away from first of
all it's understanding that most The
Athlete's dream was was to get on the
field or have the shield on your uniform
and make it all the way there you don't
necessarily grow up with paychecks on
your wall you grow up with posters of
the people you aspire to be the fact
that the money now comes with the
success of what you did on the field is
something that you don't really think
about going into it so then it's
thinking about what were those
fundamentals you did in life to make you
successful on the field what are those
fundamentals now we now have to address
you know off the field so how is your
relationship with investing change since
your first year in League to now I would
say I'm just more educated in in the
realm of investing with Joe is like okay
he sends me a deck and you know I have
to really read it and educate myself on
what I'm investing you know saving 80
percent net of my taxes and then you
know invest in some of that and then a
long-term goal of what do I want to see
myself doing after football what are
those Investments that he sent you that
you got really excited about he sent me
a wine investment one day and I mean
that just goes back to one of my
passions I call myself a wine
connoisseur but
just just him sending me that is like
okay he he knows me he understands me he
he sees me more than just an athlete
like he knows my passions what are some
of those things that you see a lot of
athletes start to invest in that you
think is genuinely a good investment
using wine as an example early on you
know one of my philosophies was if you
drink it drive it wear it or eat it we
don't invest in it like because you know
that there's a lot of pitfalls that come
on that side of it young people as
they're looking to invest for the very
beginning is thinking about the
different buckets that you could live in
he knows he's got 80 percent of his
money being saved net of taxes it's
going into a Safety and Security bucket
that eventually is going to go into the
second bucket which is a growth bucket
that is very boring disciplined dividend
income producing real estate and if you
feel that the security bucket and the
growth bucket that will you'll live off
of in the future then you can have your
Entre spirits and really dig into that
and your wine would be in that bucket in
terms of you know where you want to take
that so that even if certain things
don't work out long term you still have
the other two buckets one where you like
I need to make more than this I want to
be an entrepreneur when did that start
for you it was two years ago when I ran
in a track meet and I seen how everybody
after the trackman was like thank you
for bringing so many eyes to the sport
and I'm like okay if I can do this with
track then my name and carry some weight
so why not just capitalize off of that
right now while I'm still playing what
is your advice to them about how it goes
into their career how it goes into their
business I think some of the processes
that you take on now is you know how do
I be the best teammate how do I be a
leader in the locker room and then how
do I translate that to what you want to
accomplish meaning how do I build that
locker room in life but if you conform
that now it's a natural transition from
when you're playing to when now you're
performing in business and in Hollywood
and all the other other endeavors he
wants to do what is that relationship
like with your teammates my first day in
the locker room I've met three people
Russell Wilson Bobby Wagner and Dwayne
Brown all of them all Pros I want to be
where they're at so when a rookie walks
into the locker room that's my goal is
they come up to me and and start asking
questions last year was the first time
that happened with me with Ken Walker
his lock is right beside mine and so he
would ask me Financial questions and he
looks at me like a big brother for me to
be able to give him a well thought out
answer and not just me feel like I'm
telling him what to do but I'm educating
him at the same time what are some of
those questions some of those some of
those good like genuine feedback that
you have the lessons that you've learned
that you pass on all right so after I
was paying my rent in Seattle for my
birthday bought myself a car but I was
also paying somebody else's mortgage at
the same time he's in the same exact
situation it's where he wants a new car
I'm like bro you you just got a new car
you don't need another car if you want
to invest in something invest in real
estate or invest in a house to where
you're paying yourself basically and
it's something that you own and when you
buy another car it depreciates as soon
as you drive it off the lot so it's just
thinking long term what are some of the
biggest lessons that you've learned
always try to be an owner so you can
have a seat at the table so you can make
decisions and and so you can show people
that you're more than just an athlete
and carving out your own your own paths
to where other people behind you can
follow and be like oh I want to be like
DK and so have you sat at some of those
tables goals like what have you absorbed
from being in the room instead of just
being a face
um that people really value your opinion
once I got the seat at the table and
people really started to listen a switch
flipped at me like okay you're not just
an athlete you can be an Enterprise I
can have my own business and partner
with other people and not just be the
second or third seat at the table wave a
magic wand
ten years after you're done playing what
are you doing sin beside Joe in a
business meeting about about to close a
multi-million dollar deal on a team or
something like that instead of my
financial advisor like this is my
business partner I definitely want to be
a team owner one day DK thanks so much
Joe thanks so much for your guys's time
thank you foreign